[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
and animal extravaganza that's right yes
this is the q a section we are going to
answer some questions
i see some good ones here on the screen
yep all right
we're going to start with some from last
episode that we didn't we
missed a lot in the last episode um but
so we're gonna pick up a few from there
one from the discord server and then
launch right into the ones that came in
last hour before finishing with
uh 20-25 minutes of questions from this
hour
all right from all your travels what is
your favorite language or
dialect and why also fairfax for
president
that is uh fairfax with the white nose
back there
along with moxie he would make a
terrible person and he
he's he's got the discretion part
everything is at his discretion but yeah
he would be an autocrat yes his um his
discernment is perhaps
a bit lacking and wise for his years
which ain't saying much
yeah yeah um all right you got one
no actually so i thought this was
interesting because um
you know we've talked we we have been a
lot of places and
neither of us is particularly adept at
picking up other languages
yeah um but we've we've dabbled in many
and we always try to
try to learn enough wherever we are to
at least
um make it clear that we're trying um
and long ago when we were in madagascar
um i had the thought that actually it
seems like
maybe every language out there does
something best like this or
or maybe no the it's not quite that it's
that for every concept there's some
language that actually has it drilled
down on
most effectively and so in malagasy for
instance they have this word sipa
which means um sort of you know romantic
partner
but it doesn't it's not yet married so
they you know they do have of course
marriage in madagascar but it also
doesn't have the sort of triviality of
boyfriend or girlfriend it's also it's
gender neutral
and it doesn't have the sort of clinical
thing of partner
and you know really if you are
romantically involved in someone and not
married
you refer to your sipa and um it seems
to do so much
of a better job than any of the words
that we have in english
um so that's that's not an answer but um
i won
i wondered if you hadn't answered this
one i do but i first want to say about
cipa i also recall a discussion i'm
trying to remember which malagasy person
this discussion was with
but um it turned out that the
reason in all likelihood that cipa does
such a good job
of being a non-trivial version of
a boyfriend or girlfriend is
that the economic
obstacles to marriage are so substantial
that many people
are effectively married but haven't
gotten the resources to have the
ceremony
and therefore it's sort of this higher
um higher standing
yeah in fact you have um you have people
with
um children sometimes grown children who
themselves might be beginning to start
families
and the parents may still be sipas
because they have not
garnered the resources required
basically to throw the big party
including the sacrificing of the zebu
and some of the
some of the areas of madagascar that are
required in order to um
really effectively declare to your whole
family look we are we're taking this
seriously and we're married
the sacrificing of the zebra followed by
the grilling of the zebu which is where
you know the party really gets the zebu
being the malagasy
cattle yes um now my favorite
uh would be jamaican
patois um i love it it's uh marvelous
it's very hard to simulate for me at
least
hard to understand uh and i must say i
ran into the most
marvelous discussion you'll never guess
who
had the most marvelous discussion on
patois uh bob drivers no
john mcwhorter oh of course of course
lexicon valley podcast recent one maybe
his most recent one
was on patois and in fact the argument
he made
solved a long-standing paradox for me
which was about why patwa patois from
various caribbean islands
are so similar and his point was
it's not from those islands which i
thought was absolutely fascinating and
where it was from
uh is stunning so i would recommend
people go check out the lexicon they're
not going to tell us
well let's put it to you this way i
didn't know that a slave castle
was a thing in africa but the slave
trade obviously had all of these
elements
to it oh wow and um okay so
anyway the story is well worth well
worth a listen yeah
um so yeah we always make the mistake of
spending too much time on the on the
early questions but
um this is not a favorite language but i
do remember being particularly charmed
as well
in turkey uh with uh you know so we
we spoke no to i mean just you know
again a few words none of which i could
call to mind right now
there you go um but um
but when we would be walking on the
streets we would
inevitably be asked what do you want
kebab
yes by people attempting to buy people
attempting to get out of their kebab
shops
sticks of meat yes or um always being
invited in for apple tea
including even at a gas station the gas
station yes we were we were getting gas
which was no reason not to be hospitable
the turks are
lovely people and so we went in and we
had some apple tv apple tea
yes that's the tingman um that's not
turkish at all no that's not turkish
that is a really lousy impression
of uh now somewhere in here i don't
think we would end up getting to it
otherwise but someone asked us uh
to uh please not avoid the fact that it
is uh talk like a pirate day today
i'm not sure i can do it i i don't know
how pirates talk
of course you know how pirates talk
everyone knows how
pirates talk okay what are the possible
evolutionary explanations for
tickling yeah oh man i can't
i can't believe i'm going to deploy this
here you don't have to i just i wanted
you to see that someone was thinking
about it you've been promising to talk
about it for a while
in various venues yeah um let's put it
to you this way let's
talk about the nature of the puzzle and
um then i hey fairfax could be good
enough
um the nature of the puzzle is this
tickling has many interesting features
um you can't tickle yourself right you
just can't
um it's hard to tickle it's hard to be
tickled if you're in the water
that's interesting um or if you're
scared if you're scared
presumably on a battlefield we're
tickling a thing people would be
sneaking up on their enemies and
tickling others right exactly and they
would fall to the ground
writhing in agony and then immediately
be stabbed or shot or something
so um anyway
i believe you are on the verge possibly
of getting the giggles
no i just i don't think that we should
put you in charge of
military strategy of course you should
because you know why because
i know that tickling is not on the menu
of possibilities so unlike all of the
other military
leaders you will not uh break out
tickling as something to
to do on the battlefield many an empire
has fallen because someone has thought
that tickling their enemy was the key to
defeating them and discovered that it
just didn't work in that context
we're pointed sticks pointed sticks yes
yeah
um so i tell you what i'm gonna promise
to deploy
what i this is a very what i think is a
a marvelous hypothesis
i've had it for many years and
everything i've seen has
increased my confidence that it will
turn out to be
true but i should deploy it in a proper
form rather than deeply buried in a
q a here but do notice the pattern the
pattern is enough to tell you
what might be going on in my opinion
do any other animals
that says animals mammals do any other
animals
tend to find their identity in their
color even though they are the same
species like humans with rice and
um mammals nothing came to me exactly
although there may well be
um different uh coat colors within um
within non-domesticated species but the
example that really sprang to mind
was you you know what i know exactly you
know exactly where i'm going
um the uh bastamentos right uh so the
boca del toro archipelago
in panama has
uh many delights uh one of them
is uh that it has on it a species of
dark poison frog which was the first
clade of uh
frogs that i was studying with regard to
their sexual selection and territorial
behavior and parental care behavior
um and it's it's no longer dinner babies
it's oophagia i think premillio
and they have in the bocas
archipelago so many morphs it's really
incredible so
in costa rica where they are more common
they're called the blue jeans frog
they're bright red on their backs they
have
bright blue legs and if you flip them
over they have these like pale neon blue
dots on their venters in their stomachs
and in mainland panama they tend to not
have blue jeans as much
but on these islands they have every
color
under the sun there are yellow ones
they're orange ones there are green ones
they're
[Music]
i don't think purple but sort of deep
blue and of course they're red
and each of them come with spots
sometimes without spots other times um
pretty much all the actually um
absolutely colored gender batteds the
dark poison frogs have these pale blue
neon blue dots on their stomachs but
when under normal circumstances
you don't normally see frogs flipped
upside down
they look so different from one another
and they do
seem to be mating assortatively based on
color
and so that's a that's a long-winded way
of
getting to an answer it's not a mammal
but it is an animal um
of an organism that is made doing mate
choice decisions based on
um based on color and
you have something there you want to
well i'm trying to find
one of these posters but i want to make
sure it's of the right species
before i forward it to zack
does that look right to you
yeah well no not all of those are emilio
so some of those are familiar but not
all of them
so um so
kyle who has done a lot of work on kyle
summers made choice in these frogs has
found a positive assorted of mating
yes i should i have not gone back and
looked at his papers but that's what i
remember
yes so let me just say whether that is
positive assertive mating meaning
um what you are like with regard to
whatever character it is that you're
thinking about you tend to choose the
same thing negative assertive mating
being
whatever character you're attending to
you tend to choose the opposite thing in
a mate
so yes they i i believe that kyle has
found kyle summers has found
positive assertive mating with regard to
color morph in oophagia pemelio
in the bocas del toro archipelago of
panama that was a lot of words that
probably are meaningless to most people
no but let's just put it to you this way
there are good reasons that this could
happen
um for example color morph may be
arbitrary
but it can be an indicator of lineage
and there are reasons that creatures
might prefer to mate at some distance
from self
but within lineage so um that is an
awkward fact but
it uh nonetheless it's not hard to find
logic by which that would evolutionarily
be
favored and i would just say i in my
dissertation
i deployed an argument whereby this
might even
work in plants right and the example i
used was hydrangeas
and the thing is hydrangeas their
color the color of the flowers is
dependent
on um soil ph
and my argument was that
plants could use the eyes of insects to
choose a mate
and they would do this if you had a
let's say blue
morph of hydrangea blue morph indicates
what soil type it is growing in so a
plant that has successfully grown in
let's say acidic soils
has gotten to the point of flowering and
is looking for a mate
well its seeds are very likely to end up
in acidic soils because if you had to
guess what soil type the seeds would
land in from an adult if the adult is in
acidic soils
the offspring are liable to end up there
so it wouldn't want a hydrangea that was
well adapted to basic soils
and so how do you figure this out if you
don't have eyes and you can't see your
mate because it's a pollen grain you're
looking for
well you might put up a blue flower to
whatever extent there's a bias in
insects towards blue or a particular
insect toward blue
that insect would tend to go from a blue
hydrangea to a blue hydrangea rather
than from a red hydrangea to a blue
hydrangea
and this could provide some bias whereby
a plant with no eyes could see
a potential mate and choose one over
another flowers
uh pollinators doing the flowers bidding
as they do in many regards but
specifically
having their eyes borrowed yes very good
plants borrowing the eyes of insects
very nice if unity is unable to run a
ticket this year
where should my vote go to best support
the success and efficacy of the unity
movement in our future
which white house helps the odds more
und 2020 for the win
short or long game this again from last
episode
fantastic question um what i want to say
to you
is i think the most important thing to
do
is not to vote so as to put unity in the
best position
going forward the problem is that you
could get into a situation
where harming the nation you know
accelerationist level thinking where
um the faster things get bad the greater
the chances that we can switch to
something better because people will be
motivated to do it
and i think this is too dangerous so
what i would say
is you need to escape the duopoly's
claim that you are obligated to do what
it says
right you you've got tweedledum on one
side and tweel dumber on
they the want to tell you what you're
obligated to do based on the
the cozy little um situation that they
have erected
was that new yeah
[Laughter]
but in any case i think what you want to
do
is vote your conscience vote what you
think
is best for the nation going forward and
i don't think this is a simple thing
in this case at all i think the duopoly
has set us up
for disaster either way and different
kinds of disaster
yep and i will say i did write a piece
before it was clear that um
trump was going to win in 2016 i wrote a
piece in anticipation that clinton would
win because that's what i thought was
going to happen
and the point of my piece which has now
been misunderstood by dave rubin who
mentions it in his book
as if i said something i didn't but the
point of my piece was
there was literally not a single thing
you could do in the 2016 election
you couldn't vote for either of the
major party candidates you couldn't vote
for a write-in as i did
you couldn't not vote without harming
some constituency
we were given nothing but bad choices
and you had to pick one which meant
that effectively at some level you owed
somebody an apology
and that that i argued was the enemy
that any system
in which doesn't which doesn't give you
a move in which you don't owe
somebody an apology for having made it
is a sick
system and we need to fix that so um
in that light i would say do your best
vote your conscience
don't listen to the goddamn duopoly
because it's what put us in this mess in
the first place
and uh yeah if we can't win this time
the question is uh unity until we get
there
yeah unity doesn't die uh with the year
nope absolutely not
my question is only a few sentences long
but doesn't fit into the super chat
limits even at the 500
level please consider another tool in
the future happy to code one up for you
for free if need i believe in what
you're doing so i wanted to include this
just to say that um
someone else who who watches regularly
has offered to do just that and is in
fact working on a platform
so uh we may continue to um
uh to receive super chat questions even
after that but basically
um youtube is is predatory they take
um 40 of what you donate here and
um and they obviously are also in a
position to censor
if they want to uh so um we
that that other system is in the works
and we'll keep you posted about that i
would also
say though i can tell you're not on
twitter because twitter teaches you
how to get these things down to very
short
um snippets and you know that not all
questions can be
shortened to very very short snippets no
i do know that i do know that but i also
know
that um that one can often
get way farther than you think sure i i
learned this in
a spectacular form i once sent a
letter to the editor to the new york
times um
but they have very strict limits i think
it was a 500 word
limit or something like that it's
probably less than that maybe it's less
than that but in any case
i wrote my letter that's like that's
almost as long as an op-ed it's going to
be more like 150 words
yeah maybe 150 words but in any case i
wrote something and it was more than
twice the length they would accept and i
set about trying to figure out how to
get it down to the
word limit and i did and the thing that
i was shocked by
was that it actually tightened it up
quite a bit there's a lot of extra
verbiage in there
yeah well i i won't tell my horrifying
editing story right now but um
but yeah often you really can tighten
things a lot and then there's a point at
which
you try to tighten it further and it
decoheres and you lose all meaning
now i believe that in this case much
like with twitter
this person could break their question
into a couple
of different ones and they could file
them together and we would see them come
in together
yep um so anyway that's a possibility or
you can wait till the
better platform emerges that's right
okay so um
i've told the people on discord uh that
uh once a week
uh we will if they want to pose
questions amongst themselves and vote on
what question they would really like to
have answered we will do so so this is
the discord question for the week
you have both talked about the negative
effects of casual sex culture and how
sex is for bonding
in pairs in light of this how should
people be dating and what place does sex
have in an individual's life prior to
marriage or the equivalent
what advice could you give to younger
people as the age for marriage rises in
the western world
well first thing to say is there's
nothing to recommend casual sex you
should dress up a bit
and then dress down i guess that's sort
of yeah
yeah almost required sort of an
oscillating level of dress is what you
recommend
you start out dressed a bit more
formally than than all the casual folks
i guess but
um all right so neither of us has ever
um
said um and i at least have not thought
that the idea of sex outside of a formal
institution
of of marriage or even
coyotes i think we got coyotes outside
our window yeah
all right um hold on hey zach
yeah why don't you go have uh toby make
sure that all the cats are inside and
lock them down okay
yep yep um all right
that's that's close and it's the middle
of the day so
you think it's coyotes i'm not 100
certain it could be dogs but i think
it's coyotes but we definitely we
definitely have coyotes here yep okay um
what were we talking about casual sexual
sex and marriage
um and maybe that's just coyotes having
sex i don't know could be
hard i don't know what they sound like
when they have sex um
you know sex sex what we'd have spoken
against is um extremely casual sex and
the idea that
um what you know men at their sort of
second worst
so you know not not rape but um seeking
the sort of
the so-and-go strategy which is what one
of your students once called it right
um is not particularly interesting and
certainly not honorable
and women aspiring to do the same thing
is neither interesting nor honorable
either
that's also bad for society it's bad for
society and it's also just not it's
you know it it's just the physical it's
just the physical stuff and so
um in in engaging in
sex with someone with whom you don't
imagine that you will be spending your
life with
can be an absolutely wonderful way to to
explore
your body and your sexuality but um that
is different from saying you need to
save yourself for marriage
or um that go into a bar because
you want to pick someone up because
you're horny and you know that you'll
never see them again
12 hours later you know both of those
extremes can be
recognized as extremes without um you
know and leave a lot in the middle to be
discussed
yeah and i mean i also just think
somehow
i don't know why we're always playing
defense on this question
the the ethos of the moment is so
backwards
that it is as if you know this sort of
it's another case where the term that's
been deployed sex positivity
is um a misnomer and
the fact is sex positivity takes one
view of sex and what its value is and
how to get there but i would just
suggest just as a proof of concept
ask yourself this question when has
sexual liberty
been greater i think the answer is
never at all sorts of levels the stigma
is gone
from pornography and masturbation
we have apps to facilitate you meeting
people that you'll never see again
and going home with them all sorts of
stuff is being
normalized sex work
how satisfied do people seem
i think they seem really unsatisfied i
think they are sexually frustrated and
that the very thing that they thought
was going to address it has done the
very
opposite it has taken the magic out of
this landscape
and replaced it with um it's junk sex
strength sex yeah now it's um and this i
mean this is a point that we make
in in our book that we were writing um
and it was a point that was really well
made with a lot of backup from
from data from various sorts actually in
a 2019 or 18 i can't remember which
atlantic article that was called i think
the sex recession yeah
which you know adds to what you just
said that actually
um many young people are actually having
a lot less sex
right that there's you know that there's
obviously a rise in casual sex and one
night stands and and
all of this but that there's actually a
lot you know people
um people seem to be uh
replacing what used to be real human
you know amazing important tactile
content
with you know screens and uh with a with
sexting as if
you know as if there is any way for that
to do you know even
a 20th the same thing in terms of
connecting you to another human being
yeah and you know people are being
synchronized that this uh
the competition in the porn industry to
get people's attention
has resulted in this move in the
direction of extreme stuff
uh in many cases insane stuff
dangerous things that for the most part
women don't want to have anything to do
with it
epidemiologically ill-advised things
so anyway it's obviously not working
it's obviously
compromised things that do work and i
think i think the problem is
that uh the term casual sex itself
and the fact that you feel the need to
separate
an objection to casual sex from the
suggestion that sex needs to wait for
marriage
what it is is divorcing sex from
meaningful relationships is a mistake
right the configurations i mean as we
pointed out with the point about uh
malagasy sipas these are people who are
bonded and may produce
children but aren't married because
marriage is difficult to accomplish
right so there's lots of room for stuff
but i would say as i've said about
hallucinogenic drugs the thing is
it makes sense to seek
satisfaction sexual satisfaction is
awesome
but that is not the same thing as
treating it casually right the fact that
it's very pleasurable does not mean in
fact the route to
it being pleasurable involves one taking
it seriously right this is the whole
message of tantric sex is that taking it
very seriously is a way of elevating
pleasure and so
um the the junkification of everything a
friendship
of sex of um the whole landscape is not
serving anybody
so in terms of advice um
my advice would be figure out who also
aspires to something better
and opt out of the um
the consensus together that's what i
would suggest
all right next question the next one
refers to the fact that it is rosh
hashanah today
the jewish new year shanatova and
shabbat shalom
thank you all for your service towards
unity to me unity is more than
president and vice president it's people
engaging each other with civility
regardless of personal beliefs if unity
2020 fails we need to amplify
amplify voices like chloe valderry and
john wood jr
amen absolutely absolutely that's
absolutely the case yeah um
uh yeah and shauna tova do you as well
um
is that how it's pronounced i got
shabbat shalom right but yeah
shana toval i believe so all right i
butchered it then
um but yes unity is uh a posture towards
your fellow man before it is
anything political or particular to a
given race
that's right do you think men have a
wired in instinct to protect women
would this instinct have a negative
effect on the effectiveness of a mixed
sex military unit in a combat situation
um we tend to not use the word instinct
for a variety of mostly not very
interesting
semantic reasons but
um do men especially
in a combat situation tend to protect
those who they may view as uh less
capable or more needed protection
yeah for sure um and i'm not sure
to me that is not the main reason to be
perhaps concerned about a mixed sex
combat unit it's more about
the potential for sort of distraction
and um
and and jealousy and sexual competition
perverse incentives inside
perverse incentives inside the thing
yeah um but
um but this this is a possibility too
well i have
hypothesized elsewhere that this is why
ships are female like ships are called
females
names given female names and my my
argument is
that the uh the
what would the term even be it's not
anthropomorphizing
the femopomorphizing of ships
femorifizing femorphizing uh
is a mechanism to trigger men's um
built-in tendency to want to protect
women especially
women on whom they are dependent
and that basically ships that have
a a female place in the mind tend to
survive better
than ships that don't that's the
argument that we would evolve
to view them in this way because it does
give them
the kind of protection that results in
the people on those ships making it to
uh to shore yeah great prediction
hard to test because i don't think ships
are ever given male names at this point
um right yeah i don't know if i don't
know if through history
i don't we'll probably hear about it if
there are but
um not being an expert of uh
of ship history i don't know when that
started and if we have any
records from before then where there
were ships named with male names
actually it does strike me that we do
now give ships male names do we know
oh i guess well like battleships like we
name them for for military leaders
mccain and nimitz oh yeah
okay so yeah a little hard to test
because the uh you know we're not losing
as many ships as we once were but
um i wrote a letter to senators about
putting unity above partisanship
in filling rbg's seat if you like it
feel free to share
um uh so i'll just i'll read it's
gandt.substance.com
or if not um do you what do you think of
crickets as a source of protein
well here's the thing crickets are among
the staunchest critics of humor i find
they are absolutely unforgiving when it
comes to
atomic timing as for a source of protein
they are potentially good source of
protein but you got to get them down and
that's not that's the tough part
um they're a little yeah no i mean
insects as a source of protein um
yes we probably all should be and those
of us who have
been in places where there were for
instance you know fried grubs available
from street vendors and have tried them
and who grew up with western dietary
sensibilities are none too keen
to incorporate those into our diets i at
least am not
so it's a you know it's an individual
versus population level
uh analysis where i i i prefer my rib
eye thank you very much except except
that
i believe the market is now delivering
um this isn't going to be protein bars
that are filled with cricket powder i
believe that's a thing
i believe i did not make that up okay um
frankly
yeah we don't really eat protein bars
right like so we we
we tend towards whole foods that
resemble as much as possible the
organisms that they came from
or mixed in home in a culinary fashion
as much as possible and so the uh the
packaged
processed foods aren't for the most part
a part of our
of our diet um
if they were i would i would definitely
advocate for giving
that a try 100 you probably can't tell
you know
it's often soy protein like and you know
from people who probably don't
sit around snacking on soybeans so much
and you know as insects go
crickets are not disgusting yeah it's
not deep fried crubs
yeah yeah like you find on the streets
of coca and ecuador cockroaches
cockroaches um chocolate ants are
probably easy but that's more chocolate
than ant i expect i would imagine yeah
yeah
in his debate with dawkins brett made
the analysis that pre-positioned society
is not an error but a feature which
assists in spreading society's genes
will this also be the case for
homosexuality in modern times
yeah there's a leap in that question um
i believe it is probably a warranted
leap but
what i would say is
i don't
it is difficult to know what to make of
homosexuality
in modern times i think we are in a
scenario that is so novel that it is not
likely to serve
the role that it may have served in the
past and i'm not going to say
more than that because again this is one
of these things that needs to be
presented as a full argument not an
off-the-cuff
response to uh to a question but i do
believe
um you are very much in the right
neighborhood of
very important discovery
this is just a recommendation a request
after you finish your book i'd love to
see you two make a nature documentary
about humans approaching us as any other
species
maybe intercut videos of parallel
behaviors from other animals and really
get into the weeds
yeah i was with you until until the
weeds part you don't like weeds
um you know i the thing is their very
nature is weeds
makes them less exciting than some you
know don't you that weed is a social
construct
yes actually like it actually is i'm not
saying that to be
snarky and and mock wokism it's actually
a social concept
there is no evolutionary thing that is
weed
um it is a plant that is somewhere where
the person talking about it has decided
doesn't belong
weeds are botanical noise
but it's it's social it's it's it
doesn't include now it's not enough no
no that's not it does because noise are
the patterns that you are
not into noise are
apparently my brain is still full of a
bit of smoke
no noise noise is the best sorry noise
is the pattern that noise
i know what i said let's put it this way
here's my argument that uh i used to
make to students about signal and noise
okay okay all you got is patterns right
everything is patterns the pattern
you're interested in studying
that signal the patterns that interface
with your measurement but aren't the
ones you're studying
that's noise but you could study those
patterns too so the point is
the designation of a particular pattern
as noise is not inherent to the pattern
it's inherent to your
interest in knowing about that or your
need to exclude it in order to see the
pattern you are interested in which is
exactly the same thing
that you are arguing is going on with
weeds and i agree it is
right you're trying to cultivate these
things relative to the things that you
either are trying to cultivate or prefer
to look at
these other species are their noise they
are
the undesired botanical patterns
i can't believe i haven't convinced you
because i believe that was a very solid
argument
i'm gonna i'm gonna go like 85 on this
one not
nearly good enough okay all right i'm
i'm going to
set about convincing you yeah we'll work
on this maybe come back to it
our botanical noise
what did you say zach 35 minutes we're
gonna spend a couple more
minutes on this one before we switch to
the next one
um you say that females
produce large gametes and males small
gametes and this is one of the clear
differences between the sexes
how does giant sperm fit into this love
your podcast don't ever stop greetings
from denmark denmark cool
um i don't know anything about giant
sperm never heard that before
but the large versus small is a bit of
a semantic shortcut so what the
distinction really is
is um lacking in cytoplasm and
able to move so tends to be small
because it lacks in cytoplasm and able
to move
it's zippy or motile that's sperm and
full of cytoplasm uh and um
and sessile which is what eggs are so
giant sperm whatever
whatever that is i don't know if that
brings a bell for you there may well be
some gametes that
are male gametes that are much bigger
than would be expected
um but if they still lack cytoplasm
um they are still most 100 fitting into
the male gamete model of
no cytoplasm therefore no ability to
render themselves a zygote by selfing
for instance
um now that said are there errors you
know or
is it possible there's sperm that end up
with cytoplasm in them that are errors
sure it's a complex system uh you know
the history of of
of of sexual reproduction is it possible
maybe but i've never heard of them so i
just want to point out that this is
actually we have just landed
in the same place as the discussion from
if you'll think all the way back to live
stream
45 our last live stream
um we had a discussion about squamates
snakes
in which there was a reversal of
the system from z w to x y am i correct
you remembering that yeah so i asked the
question when we were talking about that
what had switched did you have a
consistent line of male and female that
had switched its chromosomal
uh mechanism and i said probably not
because it almost certainly
um evolved separately from a
environmental sex determination
system rather than moving from one
chromosomal sex determination to another
so the question is if it had a
reversal in other words if you had a
system
not like you're describing where you had
chromosomal sex determination
and it's flipped from cw to xy that is
to say whether
males or females are the heterogametic
sex
then you would have had to have a shift
in
um what style of gamete was produced
because as you have been pointing out
for months and months and months and
months
on these podcasts um the
motility of gametes is the consistent
diagnostic
character motility and presence or
absence of cytoplasm
those are the two things um those are
the two characteristics
so i don't like presence or absence of
cytoplasm because it's obviously
continuum
um but so i don't disagree that we see
a discrete difference in well and eggs
can move a little bit i mean
neither of these are perfect binaries
modal motile versus not
cytoplasm versus not they're not perfect
binaries whereas
male versus female pretty much is right
but i guess my point would be
the um you can do
a relative calculation of size and
motility
inside of any species
and a reversal might well involve
something
like sperm that are suddenly
disproportionately
large you can imagine a small error in
the developmental process of sperm that
caused that
and allowed a flip i'm willing to say
that that would be possible
if it were possible that you would have
a
switch in the type of chromosomal sex
determination system
i don't think that that thing has ever
happened i don't think
that we have any evidence that the basal
state of being of having environmental
sex determination
hasn't produced separately all of the
examples of genetic sex determination
that we have
that is to say um you know even so the
example from last livestream was
we've got this parthenogenetic python
and it turns out that in boeins
which includes both the boas and pythons
there's two apparently different
evolutions of the um
it's going to be they have the xy system
i can't remember which it is yeah i
think that
i can't remember which which most snakes
have um
maybe yeah i think most snakes have the
zy system zw system
and boads um two different times have
evolved in xy system
and it is not imagined uh that one of
those systems evolved from the other but
rather that all three of them evolve
from the basal state
of having environmental sex
determination so i
agree with you on the likelihood of
these things evolving i don't know why
you would imagine that you never get a
reversal
i mean for one thing these in plants
chromosomal reorganizations are common
like
triploides and plants are weird
no they're not well the whole
non-segregated germline thing makes them
makes it
a different kind of analysis they're
different but um
you know none of it's weird you've got
plants it's all weird
okay it's then it's all weird but my
point would be major chromosomal
reorganizations
are commonplace in plants for reasons we
get um
in animals they're tougher but we see
evidence of lots of reorganizations and
we don't know how they happened
um so my point is you've got some big
hidden landscape of chromosomal major
chromosomal changes that were not
catastrophic
it might end up i mean we're really in
the weeds for most people here but it
might i wonder if it might not accompany
uh changes in ploidy
uh so you know we're so we are diploid
we've got
uh 20 humans have 23 chromosomes each of
each egg or sperm is just 23
but every other cell of your body has 46
that's you know
23 is the haploid number 46 is the
diploid number
uh i believe that chimps they're one off
22
and 44 i think i don't think it's the
other direction but they're one off of
us
um whereas uh frogs for instance
um have just an incredible rate of
polyploidy of just like
doublings triplings octuplings of their
ploidy numbers
and this has all sorts of cascading
effects most of which i think we don't
yet know and i wonder if
somewhere in these sort of you know
ploidy doublings and triplings there
might be the opportunity for some kind
of funky
switch toggle of genetic sex
determination that's exactly what i'm
getting at and you might even do an
explorer mode thing
where the ability to flip is
uh retained in a latent form and
a ploidy shift allows it to become
manifest um this does remind me
there were a couple of corrections i
wanted to make and i should have done
them on the main livestream oh yeah
um one a former student of mine desi
rose
contacted me and said that there had
been parthen
parthenogenesis in turkey as she thought
and i looked into this a little bit
and it turns out so you and i have
looked at this separately what i
got to was that we see evidence of
embryos that are produced this way but
nothing
doesn't go viable yeah chickens and this
is and i didn't i
i wanted to talk about it too on the
main live stream and then you know ruth
bader ginsburg up and died and it sort
of threw everything into into chaos but
the little bit that i looked into uh
suggests that yes some domesticated foul
and there may be some example from a
pigeon as well which obviously isn't
usually domesticated although
sometimes are there effect yeah
right so um it seems that the ability to
produce eggs
absent in emails um has been noted in in
many cases
in chickens and turkeys um but that may
be never
or if ever extraordinarily rarely do
those eggs end up becoming
being viable enough to hatch so there is
embryo but
that parthenogenetic embryo therein
doesn't seem to be viable
right my prediction would be um well
a it's conspicuous that it's
domesticated and human-associated
birds that show this pattern but b i
would suggest that that means
that if we look long and hard enough in
nature and
zoo animals eventually we're gonna find
this we're gonna see it
um okay that's one correction second
correction
which is i'm i'm i'm groping for some
mechanism to connect it to this but i
find
nothing oh it's not gonna be wolverines
oh no it's not wolverine okay can i go
wolverines then
you got you please okay um so i we had
i had said i thought wolverines were
hibernating i don't know what do they do
do something so
i think i think they don't i have not
looked into it fully fully but what they
what they do do which is sort of the
vision that i had in my head
um is that they build these ice dens
these snow dens
and that they do store sperm they do so
they mate earlier and they store sperm
and then implants in particular the
zygote becomes fertilized implants at a
particular point
or actually i'm not sure if they just if
they store sperm or they delay
implantation or both i'm not sure which
it is but they control the timing of the
reproduction
regardless of exactly when they've made
it back in the summer
and then they give birth in these snow
dens in the winter and
the mothers don't hibernate they
continue to go out
um but their babies um persist in these
in these snow dens
um and are born at the right moment such
that um
at the point wherever they are
latitudinally when they can come out and
begin to make a life for themselves
presumably while being taught by their
mothers they can do so so
they do not i i had said i thought they
hibernated
i don't think they do no instead it is
these
structures built at the fringes of the
habitat making them
edgeworth snow dens wow okay
all right yeah yeah you know yeah it is
what it is no it's good
yeah um okay my other correction
um i made allegations in our last
podcast
cast aspersions i cast aspersions in the
direction
of uh duke newsom yeah who it turns out
does not exist
because his actual name is hawk newsome
yeah and so i
must apologize to you hawk i blew it i
still think people should check out the
podcast the braver angels podcast
with john wood jr hawk newsome and
not gavin newsom i don't think evan
newsom is even aware of it but
i could be surprised okay um but bob
woodson and
anyway that discussion john wood junior
hawk news
woodson jr as well might be i don't know
i think it's bob woodson
but anyway uh huge fans of uh
of john and bob and um
hawk newsom being the guy from that
famous um
piece of video at the trump rally where
he um
uh was very generous and reached across
the aisle okay
okay so um oh boy
how long how far are we in zach
okay so we got a switch but i did want
to just um
we will pick up a few more of these next
time for sure
um i did want to read this one this was
just fun imagine it takes 60 minutes for
a virus that doubles every minute to
fill a jar
what percentage of the jar will be full
at five minutes to the hour
if you were an average virus when do you
realize you're running out of space
and then it says credit al bartlett and
it and i didn't realize when i first
read this that the
number it then gives is the answer but i
wanted
um just to just to quickly do like the
back of the envelope
logic that allows you to quickly get
there because this is the kind of
question that
um i see i'm like oh good let's figure
it out and i think a lot of people
because of their atrocious math
education are like i have no idea how i
would even begin to get there
so the question again is imagine it
takes 60 minutes for a virus that
doubles every minute to fill a jar
what percentage of the jar will be full
at five minutes to the hour
so i think this question needs to be
rephrased as
cells or something virus doesn't
it's very hard to do this with virus so
as a total abstraction yeah but i can i
can read it as cells or
you know bacteria bacteria is easier
yeah bacteria
we know the model from bacteria and um
and exponential growth
um so uh i would you know for me i would
just cluj this there's
clearly an elegant mathematical way to
answer the question but i would include
you because you only have to go five
minutes back so at the hour it's 60
minutes
at zero minutes back you're at 100 it
doubles every minute
um go back one minute you're at 50 go
back two minutes you're at 25 percent
go back three minutes you're at 12 and a
half percent go back four minutes you're
at
six and a quarter percent and go back
five minutes and you're at three and
eight percent so you're about three five
minutes to the hour
uh that jar is going to be full at the
hour but five minutes beforehand you're
still only three percent full
yep the lesson here being um
one should spend a good deal of time
thinking about exponential growth
before you decide how comfortable to be
about any process that has that
exponential aspect to it bingo
yep that's exactly right all right
um okay next
first question in the new hour is from
holly math nerd our friend holly who
just
put problematized a number of things
that your brother
eric put out asking for um
so on twitter everyone who is not
following
this this account holly matherd should
look for her
uh twitter thread um problematizing
god what does she do she does um a
programming language she does pickles
she does pants um as a response to eric
saying okay guys
how would you pitch this thing as as a
problem in
in woke world and she just does a
brilliant job because she suffered
through what three something diversity
classes diversity training classes
um as a as a college student and i'll
bet all of those diversity classes were
the same
yes she asks please talk about the
princeton investigation by the doe the
department of education
uh as an effective pushback tactic a
hilarious troll
or both so i thought we might end up
getting to talk about princeton
today in the live stream i don't know if
we want to say just a thing about it
here
since we may never get to it in the main
live stream and um
save a longer discussion for later
probably um
but so i mean the the very brief version
is
the president of princeton um i remember
how to pronounce his name whatever it is
at the moment um you know where we are
i'm actually visiting fellows at the
moment um
in response to the claims of the
intersectionalists and the
postmodernists and the woke and all
these the critical race theorists
that there is racism everywhere and they
can't escape it um acceded to their
claims and said yes
you know princeton is and has long been
a you know a source of systemic racism
and we apologize yada yada
i'm not quoting him directly of course
to which almost immediately like within
24 hours
the department of education uh wrote
princeton a stern letter saying that if
in fact it was
a font of systemic racism that was in
blatant violation of uh several laws
in the country and they really needed to
get their act together as the federal
government was going to come get them
and obviously this is all a little bit
of a caricature and i'm not
reading from anything but um uh
effective pushback tactic or hilarious
troll or both
kind of both yeah i mean it's it's funny
like it
and it it's one of these things where it
gets done and you think
oh yeah how is it that all of these
places are claiming
that they are in severe
um violation of the law
and uh and the law isn't doing anything
about it well because everyone knows
that
they're lying that they're not in severe
violation of the law but if they're
going to continue to claim this
they don't get to have it both ways
either you admit that you
aren't actually engaging in systemic
racism at the level that these
loons that you're letting run the
institution are are
telling you you are or you accept that
um the effects of your actions of your
claims are that well then there's going
to be an investigation
so it's actually perfect it reminds me a
little bit
of uh something that happened during the
the evergreen meltdown
where you know the the rioters were
accusing people very prominently they
were accusing the president of the
college of being
uh full of racism and by gesticulating
with his hands engaging in
microaggressions against people of color
or something like this
and at some point the president
experimented
with getting ahead of this and saying
that he was
taking steps to deal with his own racism
and instead of embracing this they were
like aha
we told you he was a racist and here
he's admitted it
yeah yeah so
why why think you can beat these people
at their own game how about point out
that their game is dumb
well their game is heads i win tales you
lose therefore
anybody who thinks they're going to win
is it it's not just it's not just unfair
it's also just
insane and dim and hello
this this one is neither insane nor dim
no no
um all right
uh jordan peterson discussed with
jonathan height
yeah jonathan height i know um jordan
peterson discussed with jonathan height
a study in plos one
called pathogens and politics that
claims pathogen prevalence predicts
authoritarian attitudes
have you heard of this do you have
thoughts so uh just for those not in
academia
or in science academia plus one is an
open source
peer-reviewed uh journal scientific
journal
that's quite good i don't know i haven't
heard of this
before a discussion
um probably if it's a discussion between
jordan peterson and jonathan hype this
is from a while ago since
jordan hasn't been public for a little
while at this point
um called pathogens and politics
that claims that pathogen prevalence
predicts authoritarian attitudes that's
that's interesting and you know it calls
to mind
of course um um
the discussed stuff no um why can't i
think of um
the the parasite
parasite and sexual selection work that
you were yeah that you were working on
with servers and lizards
um you know the idea of looking for um
correlates of of
pathogenicity uh in other in in
other social spaces but females are
evaluating
males for evidence that they are free of
pathogens
in species where um basically the males
are only
delivering gametes and therefore the
females would be doing this in the hopes
of getting
immune systems that are either
particularly effective
or particularly well targeted to the
pathogens in the current environment
i should say i think that hypothesis has
some merit to it but it is not the
overarching explanation
for these lex species yep um but anyway
so do you know about this conversation
with height and peterson i don't yeah
uh sounds sounds fascinating but i can't
say more than that
uh follow oh uh
follow-up ah so this is a follow-up to
echo's last question a question from
last time which was about um
the one that we couldn't quite parse
around immigrants
marrying um uh
immigrants coming in and marrying people
of the dominant culture
and what the sex the sex not ratio but
the
sex representation would be we don't
even have the language to speak about
this
um so she says follow up most eurasian
euro african and euro caribbean people i
know who were born in 1970s 1980s
have european moms some born later have
european dads
also mixed couples get more disdainful
looks when the man is european
um do you see a pattern is it specific
to europe
thank you so um echoes in in europe
um and
that's i mean that's that's an
interesting observation and i
just i haven't seen it myself i haven't
i haven't noticed this
um in fact yeah i would predict it the
other way
actually so i'm i'm very curious about
what the actual pattern is i don't know
explain something that may or may not be
a pattern right
um and i would also want to know if it
was local to
some group of immigrants or if it was
general uh
but surely that data exists somewhere
yeah um
is that all yeah okay uh heather
you said what we can't do is have
discretion held within particular
demographics
surely you see the issue with giving
children full autonomy can you be
certain they should not extend any other
demographic
um
obviously children is is different and
um
some people now are arguing that they're
not and that's not correct
well anybody who is not in a position to
make
good decisions right but then you know
so then you know discretion
um that all of these have slippery
slopes somewhere along the way
right so he's not in a position to make
um
good decisions um what about people who
were deemed
uh not smart enough to be able to
have children and therefore had their
reproductive uh
rights taken away from them when they
were not able to make a decision
on their own uh you know there is a
there is a long history of
a racial bias in that uh in the early
part of the 20th century and i think the
19th century in the u.s
and and even i think among just
lower-class
uh white people in the u.s so well but
i'm not sure why we end up inheriting
responsibility for
um i'm just saying that policy of the
past you know is there room for policy
you know
does society have a right to exert
discretion over the reproduction of
people who do not have the capacity to
take care of offspring
because they are mentally compromised
right i i believe it is
i would argue obvious that society has
some
right to navigate that question i don't
want responsibility for
you know navigating on the fly exactly
where the
you know the line needs to be drawn i
have no idea right
yeah but i don't want to grant that
because there have been abuses of this
discretion in the past that discretion
is suspect because it's clearly not
yeah now i'm actually i'm um
i'm thinking about you know i won't i
won't give anything away for privacy
reasons but i'm thinking about a woman
we once knew
who's um whose firstborn daughter
uh was developmentally compromised quite
a bit and
uh upon becoming of age upon becoming a
young woman
um was also quite an attractive young
woman but really did not have the
ability to understand
the new sexual attention she was getting
um nor
the her mother the woman we knew felt
would she have been
in any way capable of of taking care of
a child herself
and she the mom the woman we knew
made the difficult decision but she felt
a hundred percent absolutely the right
decision
um to uh provide for her daughter
uh an endogenous form of birth control i
don't remember what it was but something
wherein
she would not get pregnant no matter no
matter what um
and as far you know we have we've lost
touch with her over the last couple of
years but um
you know there was no there was no sense
that she was worried about
um about her daughter having
having sex forced on her although
obviously that's a risk always but
it was that she was finding in her new
sexuality
um this sort of freedom that she had had
not felt before because she was
constrained by her very developmental
deficits
and um would not have been capable of
making decisions
that would preclude pregnancy so that
was a within family decision that was
still wrenching because the daughter had
no way of even understanding what was
happening to her
but it seemed absolutely important but
you know i feel completely comfortable
with a mother
doing that as opposed to the state
coming in and saying
uh we're going to do this to all
children with an iq of less than
you know 70 or so i agree the right the
right
or the best place for this to be
resident is somebody who has the
person's interests
at heart by virtue of being family yeah
that said there's obviously a landscape
here that requires
uh nuance and discretion and
yeah i'm sure that will get pushed back
but nonetheless
um what is your hypothesis on new
technologies
such as smartphone and their profusion
of information on brain development
oh we've got a lot of thoughts on this
um
yeah i mean it's obviously destructive
it doesn't mean every aspect of it is
you know the ability
to access information the ability
to tune into things that are true to see
how life is in other parts of the world
the ability to find
rare people to interact with that you
would never encounter otherwise
there's lots of positive stuff but
overarchingly
it's a novel phenomenon that has
perverse incentives
throughout the model that deploys it and
it is creating uh psychological chaos
yeah i'll leave that there for now um
this is written very sparsely but i
think i know what the question
what it actually says is rogan retracts
wildflower wildflower
rogan retracts wildfire arrests citation
thoughts question mark um so uh he had
you probably know more about this story
than i do yeah he uh in his
podcast with douglas murray he had said
that there had been arrests
of uh protesters who had set fires
now there you know i believe that what
actually happened is ambiguous there
is at least one instance of a fire that
was quickly put out by
civilians i think that was started by
fireworks in the context of
or at least plausibly linked to
protesters but let's just say that the
you know what we were complaining about
on our last live stream was
that we don't have a trustworthy
mechanism for determining whether or not
you know certainly the pattern that you
revealed
the smoke being right up and down the
five suggests some sort of
anthropogenic process let me just say
incidentally with regard to that
um two things
that's upon looking at that again so
this again is something we talked about
in episode 45 and i showed these fires
all starting on september 8th just in
this line this
this north-south line in oregon and up
into washington
um i think that was farther east than
the five um but the fact that it was a
line
looks makes it look anthropogenic very
much so
that said and actually i got a question
i think over the email that caused me to
to remind me that oh of course one of
the other
um anthropogenic but not um you know
intentionally nasty sources of fire is
power lines
and in fact in some places where the
winds were picking up preemptively the
power grids got shut down so there
wouldn't be
fire started um so um that might that
that might have been along
another road i think i think it was not
actually the five um but it might have
been along another road which probably
would make more sense anyway because the
five's by far the you know the the
biggest interstate um
the busiest one um but it might also
have been
um you know that that high wind event
and a bunch of power lines um banging
together doing whatever
it is that they do in wind that that
causes sparks and causes fires
sure there's also uh elevational stuff
so to the extent that you have a line
uh every so often if you fly into the
pacific northwest you notice that you
have volcanoes
sticking up in a line yeah in the
cascades and
that obviously impacts weather and you
could have a phenomenon where lightning
uh was accompanying uh some weather
system passing through
oh that's interesting a
non-anthropogenic reason for a line
okay yeah um but anyway um
so i don't think we know how these fires
started in many cases in a few cases we
do though
we do know in a few cases we do know i
don't know that it has anything to do
with the protest but we
there's very conspicuous stuff
surrounding the fire down in medford
southern oregon yep um so anyway
rogan clearly got it wrong he followed
some wrong information that suggested
that we knew more than we actually know
and he did the right thing which is he
retracted it um you know he put up an
instagram post which i
tweeted i said this is what an honorable
person does when they discover that
they've made a
an important mistake and so anyway i
thought it was a good model
um but you know people of course are
going to take it to be evidence of you
know some problem with rogan on the
other hand
no it's evidence of it's
evidence quite to the contrary right in
fact he's a decent
he's a fundamentally decent guy and he
puts out
so many hours of content across so many
different topics that it's surprising
how rarely he needs to do something like
this so
um anyway very much so yeah
uh i'll fight you naked says i'm not a
trumpkin
but police no i'm not a trumpkin but
peace
between israel and uae israel and
bahrain
saudis possibly joining soon 5000 troop
drawdown
serbia kosovo peace deal wow
yeah that's that was all the question
and i
i agree um yeah dude is doing some good
work
and uh i didn't see that coming yep i i
agree
it very much complicates the uh argument
that
you know everything trump does is is bad
and he yes it does rather rather yes
um ever felt aaron five minutes okay
we're gonna get
uh a couple more in here
have you ever felt that you were going
to be forced to violence
how often is it the only option
realistically could you if you had to
practically or morally that's a lot of
questions
yeah well you got your answer
no i don't have a a answer i might i
might respond
and riff with you or or i might let you
answer and then i'll yeah come back to
another time
um i think there's a high likelihood
that this
comes to sort of widespread violence
and i you know i'm desperate to avoid
that outcome
i don't know there's a question so this
question is about an individual this is
not about
the societal level stuff this is about
um
like you or me as individuals
um being felt that we were forced to
pass you you can answer the society
level question but
even in rereading it i still think the
answer is the same okay um
you know forced to violence by what by
an individual that could happen
um by a larger force that could and may
well happen
you know one doesn't know there is this
phenomenon
that most people are emotionally
devastated
if they have to kill right it's
something that people discover
that they are not suited to it and so
one never really knows until
you've been in that situation um whether
or not
you're you know in the group that can
handle it or can't but i do have the
sense
um how can i say this so i don't get
myself in terrible trouble but i guess i
would say
i don't if i had to kill
it would be because it was the right
thing to do
you know i think i would be if i killed
somebody if i hit somebody in the car
through my own negligence right which
could happen to any driver i think i
would be
really messed up by that fact for the
rest of your life
right but if i killed somebody out of
necessity
i don't think it would trouble me if i
killed somebody because they
were you know a threat to me or you or
children right i think the answer is
it's actually philosophically so
clear that um i would not be troubled by
the fact
of having to end somebody's life
i think um i don't think that's true
i think analytically that's true um but
i think you would still
um i i think almost any of us
uh would still
have a hard time coming to grips you
know if we'd never done it before
especially hard time coming to grips
with i mean having ended someone's life
i really don't you know my sense is one
has an absolute obligation
to tread ultra carefully there up until
the point that you have no choice
at the point that you have no choice it
is hard
i don't see the philosophical
implication if something is a threat
to one of us a lethal threat
i'm not disagreeing with uh your
conclusion about what the appropriate
behavior would be i mean we haven't
defined
what the threat would be but you know
that there are there threats that would
warrant uh
violence that would end someone else's
life yes um
clearly uh but the idea that um
what i'm objecting to is your
characterization of your expected
response afterwards as
i wouldn't be bothered yeah yeah you
would
um because you
i just some people wouldn't
and you would not be plagued with should
i have or shouldn't i have
if it was if it was if it had been clear
and of course you know part of
part of what these conversations often
are is that there was gray area was it
clear was it not but if
if it was clear and especially if there
was a a witness who could say to you yes
that was clear you needed to do that 100
then there wouldn't be any gray area
around
should i or shouldn't i have but even
with no gray area i needed to
i did it it's done uh still
there's a before and after in your life
i've killed someone i haven't killed
someone i'm not saying it
doesn't have an effect i'm saying so i
guess i doesn't have an effect and i
couldn't i wouldn't be bothered don't
strike me as having total overlap
well you know for one thing this is a
question
in advance of it ever happening it's not
a question in the aftermath of it so
of course that's a transition right
there so i'm not arguing it doesn't have
an implication
but my sense is first of all i spend a
lot of time
thinking about the fact that i
i aim to change
the way civilization functions because i
think we're in a tremendous amount of
danger
that results in the following
realization
if you change things you run the risk of
making them
worse you run the risk that there will
be downstream consequences that do
include people's death right
so that has to be something that you
reconcile yourself to
you know and all i can say is i am being
as
careful as i possibly can to decrease
the chances
but that the situation we are in you
know
we are living unsustainably in a system
with rules that are inadequate to
protect us from processes that are
already
alive well and putting us in jeopardy
so i don't i just
i don't see the difference for one thing
between
you pulling a trigger
out of necessity because somebody is a
threat to you or your family
and doing this in the abstract in fact i
think
people to the extent that people see a
distinction
they are actually miscalculating right
people's
death is a result of policy
constantly right and to the extent that
they
don't treat it seriously because they
don't actually get confronted with
the names of individuals who no longer
live because of some decision they made
they are profiting from a distortion
and so anyway yeah i hope we don't find
out but i
actually do think if the answer is it
doesn't even have to be a hundred
percent certain the point is
from where i stood was this necessary
given the information i had i think
frankly that's sufficient now if it
turned out somehow to be an error maybe
that would be uh
wildly well i mean of course that would
change things but i just i think that
you are
you are imagining a fully analytical
response that doesn't include an
emotional response
no i'm imagining that the um
analytics um actually
have an implication for the emotional
stuff as they of course of course they
do
i just died
okay
um
yeah so for i don't know if people can
hear what
zach just wrote from red from the chat
when you kill you tend to have anger
towards the person that you killed for
putting you in that position i think i
think
that's right um okay let's do two more
um how might explorer modes manifest on
the brain
human or non-human does the hypothesis
predict any particular types of neural
circuitry or psychological experience
um yeah well if we're talking about the
human brain sure um
i would say consciousness consciousness
consciousness and
consciousness as a an emergent social
phenomenon not a purely individual
phenomenon
that in effect the ability to model
a scenario and figure out what is likely
to work and then exchange that
information with others who might have
different insight into what might happen
that that is the ultimate explorer mode
and it explains
why humans are so good at moving from
one niche to another without
having to undergo a morphological or
physiological
evolutionary change so yes
100 yeah um hi
uh so actually we've got three
here that i think we can do pretty
quickly um
i don't like the abortion question i
prefer the discussion as to why in our
day and age
so many people get pregnant who don't
want a child solving that question and
social problem will fix over 90
of the issue do you have thoughts i
think
i think that's right and you know i i am
obviously not someone who
uh feels staunchly about the
right of a woman to terminate a
pregnancy at least in the first
trimester
and probably at least halfway through
the second um
no probably halfway through the second
has anything to do with me celebrating
casual sex and
the so-called sex positive movement um
it is precisely as a kind of a
it should be a last-ditch safety net
and what we should be doing is reducing
the number of abortions that are ever
um ever called for in the first place um
so i mean that is part of the
conversation that we
that we have oh 100 yeah i mean we have
a
culture that treats this
issue the issue of sex and what it is
and what it isn't
and how one might engage with it
treats it so frivolously and for such
obviously economically corrupt reasons
that we just have lost our ability
to say you know
does does civilization have a right to
have a culture surrounding sex that
results in people having healthy sexual
relationships
it does it hasn't it has an obligation
to do it and an abiding interest
in it and that we've allowed the
market and other forces to pollute this
is
very destructive and it is you're right
the at the point you get
to abortions late in a pregnancy
we're talking about many levels of
failure that didn't need to be
yeah okay um
we've actually got four more here
including one very large dollar amount
question
um and three of these are really just
comments so i'm going to read the
comments and then we'll end with this
question
okay you were wrong about confirmation
times
10 justices have been confirmed the same
day 53 confirmed within seven days the
average confirmation time historically
is 25 days
rbg was 45 days so i don't know if any
of that's true but that's
the claim here so i am going entirely
based on what i
understood biden to say i only viewed
his speech once so either i
misunderstood biden
biden misrepresented the truth which
would be shocking to me
um you know it's not like he was saying
these things off the cuff
but anyway i would love to know what
happened here presumably i misunderstood
something and i will uh i will look into
it and figure it out
okay um finally got it blm riot fever
looks exactly like a bunch of angry
toddlers who advanced their toddler play
cage in the manner of a roman legion
to pseudo formation will they ever
realize all the best
um and brett your wife is saying you
have emotions and aren't a sociopath and
would still care even if you had to kill
them
ah is that what you were getting it a
bit yes
ah but i don't think this is i don't
don't think this is where i mean i'm not
a sociopath i'm really really
really far from it but no um but i
i mean just i would ask you and this
person and all those who agree with you
yep to think about the question of
the circuitry that you have to have to
contemplate
meaningful change in the way human
beings conduct their affairs
right you are signing up for this level
of responsibility which doesn't mean i
don't take it very very seriously but it
does mean that i'm not going to allow
um that the emotional emotional
circuitry of causing
harm has already been engaged and maybe
what i'm arguing
is that if you engage that circuitry
that
however you end up is the result
of the process that one would go through
if you killed somebody and it was the
first time you ever felt that
responsibility
okay all right okay final question from
daniel how is it possible that only
trump was briefed on sars cove too
seems like the briefings that resulted
in the stock sale investigation would
have included the same intel
pelosi as third in command and chair of
the house intel committee seems unlikely
to not have had that intel yeah i
agree that it is very likely that the
intel was
widespread i must say there must be more
here than i know about
um yeah so this this person contributed
quite a bit to
to say this uh and i think i think
the subtext is um
why are we as many others are uh
putting repeatedly putting so much of
the responsibility for the response to
service cove too
on trump uh given that many other people
must have known
uh what what was true oh
disproportionate
power over the situation that's why i i
don't trust pelosi
at all did she play games here yes is
she constantly playing games
yes is trump's response in part the
result of an impeachment that shouldn't
have been
right yes so it's
i'm not making excuses for the
democratic
leadership but i do think the president
had a unique position
from which to do the right thing and um
and frankly he didn't in part um
because he doesn't seem able to surround
himself with trustworthy advisors
he ends up alienating uh all the people
around him with the with the barest
exception of a few people in his family
and a leader needs advisers that they
trust
and that who can speak uncomfortable
truths to them
and who are not at risk of being fired
at a moment's notice because they said
the wrong thing or hurt the guy's
feelings
and i mean this really in some ways
seems like the biggest
weakness of him as a president that he
is
there is no trusting that he will
learn from and be able to do the right
thing in another situation because
if the next situation looks entirely
different from any prayer situations
um he he doesn't have advisers around
him
who whom he trusts and who speak the
same language
and who can say to him you know what
you're gonna need these three experts
and i don't know who they are but my
good friend this or my trusted
advisor this tells me that these are the
people you know and it's not it's not
that we're arguing for
authority and experts on everything but
but having no ability to seek the advice
of others
and to add that into your model even or
especially when they disagree with you
is a huge liability yeah i would point
out though if we zoom out on this
question a little
bit um i do find it interesting um
we take a lot of crap for how hard we
are on
the democratic party and there's often
this question about well why are you so
hard of the democratic party you know
are you really cryptically you know
in favor of trump or something like this
and you know it's an interesting
question
i'm hard on the democratic party i think
because i'm sick and tired of being it's
[ __ ] captive
right they have been taking my support
for granted for virtually my entire
adult life and i'm angry about it right
the republicans
were hostile to me but that was their
role
right they were in opposition to
what i what my values told me was right
now less so than they once were
in many ways right the republican party
has become more hospitable to
many of the rights that i hold dear and
all but in any case
i do think the fact that some people see
us
as holding trump uniquely responsible
and other people uh want to convict us
of letting trump off the hook and
holding the democrats responsible as
evidence that actually we're doing what
we're supposed to be doing
which is analyzing these things and
trying to apportion blame
as it fits and you know
try it you'll find out what happens
you'll be in the same spot yep
yep all right uh well
believe it or not we actually we will
return to some of the questions that we
missed from the first
uh the first super chat from today but
we actually got through i think all of
them
from this hour uh so that's that's a
first
i believe um we may be back before
saturday
i'm not sure if so it's probably going
to be wednesday not tuesday
if you join my patreon
within the next 44 hours at the 11
up level you have a chance of writing a
question that we might answer in our
next private q a
um
all right apparently wednesday has been
cancelled
all wednesdays are just this wednesday i
think it's just this upcoming wednesday
we will go straight from tuesday to
thursday somehow
that is yet to be described yeah
well not worse than it is i think it's
actually perfectly in keeping
okay fair enough um what else let's see
um either our patreons for the discord
server find our clips channel
brett will be having his once monthly
conversations at the beginning of the
month
for patreon supporters of his at the
higher levels
[Music]
we will be back at some point uh at the
latest
next week same time same place maybe
before then
hell yeah hang in there we're gonna make
it through
together somehow there it is all right
be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you